our next guests Bucky Brooks NFL Network
analyst how do you get through this lull
in the week Bucky and in terms of
getting to the championship exams on
Sunday right now I'm down in Tampa st.
Pete for the east-west Shrine game fully
immersed in the draft process we got the
east-west Shrine this week the Senior
Bowl next week so I am distracted but
looking at the college prospects that
about to make their way to army I see
that's right where we started is that
look it's it's obviously your are you
are you in full-on draft mode just yet
or you still dissecting what we had go
on last week in the divisional round I'm
going back and forth because I am a
football junkie I can't wait to see what
takes place this weekend in the
championship round but I think the
division around provided us with a lot
of yes kind of learning lessons in terms
of way teams are constructed the way
teams will be constructed going forward
this is the first time that we will see
the top force point offenses and the
final four and so for old-school defense
of God who loves defense I'm kind of
having to change my tune that offense is
what is going to take you to the
championship and whichever team comes
with the guts defense which I thought I
was gonna be the change that ultimately
wins its [ __ ] so but gonna throw the
four quarterbacks at you because our
poll question today is which QB do you
trust the most all the way down to the
least and in order for me I went Brady
Brees
I went golf at 3 and I trust Patrick
mahomes the least of the group in terms
of those four how would you put those
put them in that order in terms of
trustworthiness um it's tough because
like you want to give Tom Brady the
Lifetime Achievement Award but I think
as we go on like who has played and
played well and Pat mahomes deserves to
be up there because he's had the best
the way to display so I would go of
mahomes
mm-hmm then I would go breathe then
Brady then Jerry call and the reason I'm
kind of down on Brady and little bit is
he didn't really play well
the season and I know that he played
better in the divisional round and the
patrons are kind of finding their
identity in terms of how they have to
play to win the chip you still wonder if
you pressure Tom Brady is he gonna make
mistakes we saw the mistakes in
Pittsburgh we saw make some mistakes in
Miami and I know that as an older player
the one thing that you don't like it you
don't want to get hit so for Brady and
Febreze if you can get pressure on them
they're more likely to change with Pat
mahomes I think Pat mahomes is going to
be who he's always been I don't think
the lights in the stage will be too
bright or too big I just think this dude
is a rare player a rare playmaker and I
think he is going to death when he gets
his opportunity home Sunday NFL Network
analyst Bucky Brooks join us and before
I get to the to the college side over
the NFL Draft side of it Bucky you were
a former second-round pick and you
played offense in his sleep so you
understand kind of what's in front of
you but understand this form you know
Bucky at what point did this league
become so offensive minded to a point
where the top four scoring teams are in
theast this championship game to where
now that's all this league seems to be
kind of moving toward rather than the
old defensive ways of yesterday you know
obviously what the league did is they
made a concerted effort to make it about
the offense all of the rules over the
last ten years have been catered towards
the offense you can't touch receivers
you can't hit receivers hard over the
middle you can't hit the quarterback but
on the end they're good you can't hit
them low you can't hit them high and so
all of the rules have made it where they
basically created a freeway on the field
where everyone can just go and motor
around and not have to worry about
getting hit and so the way that you play
defense now has to change in terms of
before it was all about bully ball
trying to beat you up time to jam and
disrupt and do those kind of things
you can do that to a point you just
can't necessarily you have to be able to
live with the consequences meaning like
you have to deal with the penalties and
stuff that would come with that I will
say this though defense still matters
but you have to be able to score points
on offense and so if I
and building on my defense I'm focusing
on two areas turnovers and Reds on
defense take the ball away and make
people kick field goals as opposed to
scoring touchdowns if you do those two
things you can win a lot of games he's
the NFL Network analyst Bucky Brooks
join us and he's also the co-host of the
move the sticks podcast alongside Daniel
Jeremiah which I already know he tends
to spike around this type of years one
of the most listened to podcast Bucky
and that's where I'll transition over to
college football to the the NFL Draft
and I think I'll start with Cuyler
Murray first with a decision to enter
the draft and still seems to be on the
fence is he committed to being an NFL
player is he still have baseball in his
future how is that all going to you
think I guess go down over the next
couple months
how will teams view him there
compensates for calimary the first thing
that he can do to eliminate a lot of
questions is when he has the opportunity
to sit with coaches and evaluators to
tell him look I'm a football guy I want
to play football I want a good
quarterback in the National Football
League if he gives them a horican member
that if I am dressed as if I'm drafted
hi I'm going to be all in on football I
don't think it would be an issue the
other issue that kayla has to work
around will be questions about his size
Oklahoma just tweeted out of saying that
he's five nine seven eight Scouts who
have been through there say he's 185 to
190 and I think the thing that works
against him there really hasn't been a
precedent set for a player of that
statute to a place successfully in the
league he will benefit from the fact
that Baker Mayfield Russell Wilson Drew
Brees have had success but even with
their success some people are still
gonna say yeah but he's a much smaller
player than them the thing that works in
his favor he just stayed in the same
offense and Baker may feel when Baker
Mayfield was that Oklahoma Baker
Mayfield goes to the league hasn't house
to any working year you now can look at
calimary state and you can begin to kind
of make some assumptions on how his game
would translate into the league he is
more dynamic he is more explosive he
can't throw the ball
big time arm telling he's not quite as
precisely as accurate as baseball of
doing his last year but he certainly is
the guy that you can imagine having the
kind of success in the league and then
ultimately it's going to be a decision
for teams are you secure enough general
manager in your job where you know if I
take a gamble on calimary India's
undersized and it doesn't work out is it
going to cost me my job so those are
things that he has to work through but
is he worried being a first rounder
based on talent absolutely will he go in
the first round I think so I think it's
a high probability I would say probably
85 to 90 percent chance to go in the
first round I just believe that people
are still trying to get their their
minds around the fact that we could have
a five-night quarterback going into the
league are we ok with that based on how
the whole standards and traditions were
when it came to the scouting community
NFL Network analyst Bucky Brooks and
it's kind of to your point you talk
about Baker Mayfield in the relationship
he had with Lincoln Riley and then it's
now Cuyler Murray and his relationship
with Lincoln Riley and then you know
right now the the report is out that
Jalen Hertz the former quarterback
Alabama will transfer to Oklahoma he'll
be with Lincoln Riley again what is
Lincoln Riley do for these young
quarterbacks that seem to not only help
out their draft stop but make them so I
NFL teams so so worthy of being a top
pick in the NFL Draft well I think the
one thing that you have to understand
about the system that Lincoln Riley
employees it is the air rage system and
so really one of the founding fathers
would be in Washington state which is
Mike Leach the system is really
quarterback friendly the thing about it
it really features a lot of concepts
that are in the West Coast often and so
the shallow crosses the stick routes
some of the other things that they do
some of those things do translate well
to the league I think the best thing
that has happened to all of the guys
that are playing under Lincoln Rowley
you're seeing other air raid
quarterbacks have success and the more
success that they have the more teams
are okay with taking guys from the
system Jared Goff came from the air raid
system at Cal right have mahomes came
from the area
system at Texas Tech Baker Mayfield
comer from Oklahoma so we've seen three
young quarterbacks come from that system
and succeed in the league they now know
that you can go to Oklahoma you can
perform well in that system and you
still have an opportunity to be a guy to
play to the next level I think that's an
easy sell for Lincoln Riley when it
comes to building recorder that I know
you're still in your initial phases of
looking at these college prospects at
these all-star games and when you start
to dive in more into the draft is there
a receiver right now that you could
possibly take in the first round or if
I'm a team do I really explore the
option of bringing on an Antonio Brown
or do you say more of a wait and see
what this draft has and go in the first
round and grab a receiver there's no one
that's going to give you the immediate
bump that Antonio Brown would give you
if your team that's in the top five or
top ten and you need a playmaker Antonio
Brown is going to be better than anybody
that you can imagine bringing on I think
the big thing when you're dealing with
Antonio Brown is what exactly are you
bringing into the locker room everyone
would tell you to a man he's one of the
hardest-working people when it comes to
football he's gonna be a guy that really
puts the time in and he's going to grind
however there other things that you have
to deal with when you bring him into
your locker yes seriously listen to what
the things are coming out of Pittsburgh
him being late him being maybe a little
diva like when it comes to you how he
had to be managed by coaches and some of
his teammates and then the fact that he
didn't play for his team the last game
for some people man that is hard to get
past that everything is on the line you
are arguably the best player on the team
and you didn't play I think before you
take on and turn your bronze you got to
sit down you got to look at the dot and
you got to get a sense of his commitment
to what you're trying to do I do
understand the fascination in the entry
based on what he's done in this league
he is without question one of the top
two or three receivers in the league but
depending on the way your team is
constructed you just have to make sure
that he's going to be a positive
influence on the rest of the squad
particularly if you have young guys in
that wide receiver I got a couple more
for you but I got to get these in just
because you know me my mind's always
going to spin
she around this draft I'm in the one
thing that we saw this year we saw
sacrum Berkeley but he was picked number
two in the type of season that he had I
possibly the NFL's Rookie of the Year
Offensive Rookie of the Year and then
you see a Phillip Lindsey who's the
undrafted guy out of Denver who has an
outstanding year as well but they're
both running backs
Le'Veon bills out there on the market
did say qualm barkley a Phillip Lindsey
that they kind of hurt the market for a
guy like Le'Veon bill or is he still
worth possibly the price that he's
probably going to garner on the free
agent market it's so funny that you
brought this up because I just had this
conversation with the running backs
coach in the league and he said look I
understand the fascination with everyone
saying hey just go trying to unwrap the
free agent outside of CJ Anderson
Phillip Lindsey who are all of these
undrafted guys that are really impactful
players in the league and it's not just
about like the stat it's about how many
undrafted running backs are making
defensive coordinators stay up at night
how many guys are revamping their
systems to deal with undrafted free
agents when you deal with the say Kwan
Barclay or Zeke Elliott or Todd Gurley
some of the other guys that have gone in
the first round you feel them a
Christian McCaffrey there's a difference
in the level of talent and it can't just
be extrapolated by fantasy football
numbers it is what do you have to do to
slow and contain them and so with the
Le'Veon bill I think every defensive
coordinator understands how special he
is and what he brings to the table at a
big body running back that is able to go
outside make plays as a wide receiver
run routes come inside pass protect and
also toke the rock hard to find those
guys and that's why when you see guys
that can do all of those things that's
why they come off the board in the first
round
I think the Le'Veon bill I don't think
it actually impacts his value at all I
think people appreciate what he brings I
think it's just a matter of being
comfortable with whatever he is going to
be in your locker room but I think he
still gets paid like Tiger Lee and David
Johnson and all those other guys last
one for you bug before I let you go back
to watching film and scouting players
what is the the theme of
this year's draft do you think so far
with all the early entries I was you
know hearing about the defensive line
heavy drab defensive players what's the
thing with this draft so far so as you
start to unwind and unpack some of these
players I think we will be talking about
playmakers defensive playmakers in
particular it is all about the D line
you talk about the past persons and D
cuts of tackles but also the off the
ball linebackers the old-school
linebackers they played a position like
used to play Kevin watch Layden bender s
watching Darius Leonard watching those
guys make immediate impacts teams are
going to look to find those sideline to
sideline playmakers who not only can
impact the run game but are dominant
against the past can they hit run and
cover those are the ones that it can
come off the board early I think we're
gonna see a lot of defensive guys go
because it's about impact in the passing
game I think you'll see a bunch of
frontline players on the defensive line
and at linebacker across the board in
the first 20 pick in the weakest
position of his draft so far I mean I
think you still kind of weak in running
back this year you won't get a consensus
first-round running back even though
there's some people that are excited
about Jacobs to running back from
Alabama it's not the kind of running
back draft that we see in the last
couple years where we've seen running
backs go in the first round I would say
that is probably the weakest part of the
dress make sure you listen to the moving
the sticks podcast alongside Daniel
Jeremiah
it'll be Bucky Brooks and always look
forward to listening to you and also
listening and also watching Tamia
listening to you on Twitter as well I
listen when you talk I listen so when
you're typing it I'm actually hearing
Bucky Brooks's voice talk to me when
you're on Twitter typing so always
appreciate the time Bucky NFL Network
analyst Bucky Brooks joining Rich Eisen
so the Rich Eisen show weekdays at noon
eastern on audience